si quelqu'un a une meilleure idée je
suis preneur on se tire
lundi dans professionnel votre nouvelle
série inédite
il y a quoi pour moi un bon petit pétage
de rotule
[Applaudissements]
dans son domaine c'est le meilleur c'est
Vincent corbeau tu une légende vivante
dans le milieu de la protection
rapprochée un agent de premier ordre
connu partout dans le monde
sa mission déjouer les complots je
cherche les agents les plus Tigneux qui
existent en attendant de les trouver je
vous embauche tous les trois
son client le plus cool des
milliardaires est-ce que vous voulez
vous ne me connaissez pas Peter Swan
Swan technologies aujourd'hui une
puissante nouvelle arme est déployée
afin de lutter contre les maladies de
notre temps
le sabotage a été commandité par des
personnes qui agissent au sein de votre
société
où que vous alliez
les risques que vous prendrez je les
prendrai aussi j'ai pas peur ça viendra
c'est un problème avec les arbres
[Applaudissements]
une équipe explosive
votre nouvelle série inédites
professionnelle lundi à 20h55 sur Warner
TV